kanzan
明日目社長です水に来ましたよ
図研製の方是非これを使ってみてください
くると7新型の
ラバーグリップローソン
ラバーグリップ付きですよホラー
これがでくるとあまりですよねまあ要する風にねちょっともう
調べてたら是非ご覧くださいどうぞ1あのメイキング船体が書いても持ち手が立たいい
のに戸塚支部することがある走行デー
安永だらしいがそれが好きでてから出血することがあるそして
でたんですよラバーグリップ付きが
阿部下げればそうだしたと思うんですけどストリップ2祝ってるッ
ずっと言ってたんですよ
製造法の今まではくると彼はこんな
見えますか
ちょっと硬いんですよねやっぱり勝数しています
けど新型は違うんですよこれ
やっぱり持つ手が一番グリップが一番違うんですよね
えっ
本当にネこのくると彼が持つてから柔らかかったら本当にねん
もうね勉強手法台ですよ
ran
しましたーー
まぁこんな感じですね
テッポウオ
すごい触り心地がう
いいですねにはね送り倒さクラビ
それ以外はあんまり
変化ないですねあーはげちゃっていっ
プレイくるとかもうちゃうのがです
bea
ヤバイっす
相撲
4ん
書きやすい
本当に来るとあの持つ手が柔らかいって言ったらもうすごいんだよ
5お色はピンクと黒と青があるんで
ぜひ買ってみてください
こう一生視聴者の方で
受験生の方もいると思うんで
最後の追い込みは
このくれとかで
頑張ってみてください
うん
じゃあな
ん